[Music]
t b welcome to Startup Nation United
very very um happy to have you here um
we had a great episode talking about ubq
and and your work and and the importance
of this company in the context of the
world in general but um but like we just
discussed your company has also been at
the front line of everything that's been
happen with the conflict and the
situation over the last 51 days really
so for Time Capsule you know November 26
it's 51 days into the war um and it's um
it's an important time to stop and
reflect on on how a company like ubq
managed to go from from tragedy but to
continue and to H to continue being one
of the one of the leading figures in the
Israel EOS system and not only business
as usual but to continue being one of
the most notable companies according to
times of 2023 and so it's a it's a great
to have you here T thank you so much um
before we even get started talking about
October 7th and the tragic events that
happened there tell me just a little bit
for context about about yourself and
about ubq just so that we have context
here all
together thank you Michael thank you I
uh I'm happy to be in in your in this
presentation with you thank you
yeah I am
a Peruan my origin and I'm here in
Israel for most of my adult
life um
ubq is a result of many years of
probably a professional experience and
uh and the and the impetus that I had as
a person always with a very
entrepreneurial Spirit but I think that
being an entrepreneur with a lot of
business and Industrial experience
ER makes it maybe easier to be one of
the those that succeed in the statistic
to you know to be able to make it um
typically they say one out of 10 or one
out of 20 startups succeed I think that
it is very very much in line with the
potential of execution team that you
have and if and if you are an
experienced person and you know how to
bring extraordinary people around you
the chances are much higher and that's
what I what we did in 2012 we uh
established ubq and since then it really
we have been H making probably good
choices and also have been very thorough
in developing this technology to that
point where today ubq is able to convert
household waste Municipal household
waste including all the Organics okay
which is the food residues and the
chicken bones and the hamburgers
and the pizza box with the pizza and the
diers and the mixed Plastics together
into a green sustainable recyclable
plastic that can replace a a oilbased
plastic this is an alternative material
that is sustainable that doesn't cause
the planet anything and on the contrary
we're solving the the the the harms of
waste and on the other hand replacing
scares and expensive oilbased resins
with a material that never existed
before which is called ubq material
that's what we incredible and so H
obviously an international company
internationally recognized company in
the in the in the um sustainability
space and in extremely equal technology
you you also for context have factories
and plants across Israel and also down
in the South
right that is correct we have uh our our
uh R&D facility which Trail into the
commercial pilot plant and then into
into the commercial plant H was
established is established in the south
of
Israel um about 35 kilometers from uh
the from gasa Street ER some of our
employees H come from U adjacent areas
you might know that around the the
street there are a number of communities
most of them agricultural
communities people that in a way were
entrepreneurs and came to develop the
land and uh and also establish a
eventually industrial facilities and
became a Powerhouse in the economy of of
this country Extraordinary People
families being in a community where
everything is is split between them it's
a very noble cause most of them are very
Pacific and Pacific you have honor of
artists uh and and and the and then some
of them uh have a very professional
degrees and we have a a number of about
20 people that come from from those
areas working in ubq in the south in our
plant and the definitely we were part of
of of these events ER of Saturday the
7th because h a good portion of our
employees do live in those affected
communities so so we'll walk me through
you know where where were you on October
the 7th morning so early morning um you
know what what was the situation for you
and and then how did things unfold for
you over the next one or two days as
sort of you were piecing together the
whole situation I live in t Aviv and
that morning October 7th the they Rock
they they fired about 2,500 missiles to
the different parts of the country
including de aiv so at 6:30 a.m. on
Saturday which is a you know our our
sacred day Shabbat and it's especially a
day of of uh of uh calmness because it
was also a
holiday so so you know ER we're sound
asleep 6:30 a.m. alarms we immediately
go to The Refuge room and the it was
very strange to get alarms all of a
sudden out of nowhere in t Aviv it was
on these were Rockets from Gaza and in
that minute when I went to the to the
Refuge with my kids ER I realized that
if I am getting Rockets most probably
all my staff living in adjacent areas
were being bombed a more times more than
me ER so I immediately send a WhatsApp H
to uh to our plant manager and
CEO and asking him how is he and he told
me look they're firing like crazy and
I'm in The Refuge room taking care of
myself but but this is a this is a this
proportionate attack and we've never
seen something like that
before um a few minutes later when when
when we could step out of the of the
Refuge room because after 10 minutes you
can go out and wait for the next alarm
if it
comes again I sent a WhatsApp and I said
how are you doing Gil fellows uh he said
t this is this is worse than we thought
I think I'm hearing a a terrorists
around us shooting all over the place
and these missiles had only been a
destruction for something even bigger
and I'm talking to you 7:00 a.m. only 30
minutes late this guy is in their fut
with her wife with his wife and and kids
and a little dog a
quiet a not knowing what happens but for
sure he's hearing shots and he's hear
hearing a robbing and he's hearing a a
lot of
noise and and he understand that he's in
a different situation than ever before
there is probably an invasion of
terrorists and there will be a there
will be a
situation ER and and and that's that's
the if you ask me how I open the the
morning at 7:00 a.m. I I was already
aware that something bad was going
on ER the outcome will evolve um in the
next hours and I was in a way ER leaving
what they were leaving because we were
on the phone most of the time
unbelievable so so what what unfolded
over the next few
hours er at 730 a.m. I got another
WhatsApp this time from uh from our from
one of our accountants her name is Nina
and she lives in
kib Gil lives in another kib it'sa which
is a lot far
away and she she said the guys my
husband must be shot please call please
call the military please call the
ambulance please help me we're hearing
shots now this is another keyboard so I
am now realizing that they are also a
hearing terrorists around and that her
husband is shot in the on the floor with
a towel trying to stop the
emage while they're trying to close the
door of the Refuge room so one little
detail that is important may need to
mention to you and uh and everyone who
is listening to us is that these Refuge
are not made for terrorist attacks
people coming in they're made to cover
you from bomb so the doors have no lock
you just close the door it's a big door
but you don't have a a system to lock it
from inside so they had be had to take
the the handle and exert counter
pressure to the terrorist trying to open
the door uh and this guy was shot and he
still was on the floor with one hand
keeping the handle and with the other
with a towel because Nina was with her
three three kids you know pampering them
and giving them Securities he had times
to to help him handle the the the the
the door and she was desperate and she
was really you know crying in WhatsApp
for for help and then we started hearing
from the others that were in the same
group in our WhatsApp group from other
kibu B for example saying exactly the
same guys we are in the same situation
we're hearing shots we're hearing
screens so in the next hours I asked my
kids to go to sleep luckily we stayed
very late that night so they were very
tired that they didn't need to be with
me I was getting whatsapps I was trying
to find you know give answer to this but
just like them these people that I know
there are hundreds and thousands of
others who I don't know who have friends
in t in other asking for the same help
so so there was a disproportionate
number of people asking desperately for
help while the terrorists were really in
hundreds going house by house shooting
everyone and you know either killing or
burning houses with people at inside the
AL light and some of them those who
wouldn't stand the the or or needed to
breathe because the house was burning
were taking as
hostages and and so at 11 a.m. we
started seeing footage from them the
terrorists were they were filming and
they were sending it to their social
media and that social media was was you
know taken by by the news here in Israel
and and we started seeing almost like
how they
conquered all these beautiful
communities and how they started just
King people and like sa just the the
most tragic thing maybe was that there
was a a peace
concert in in an adjacent there were
thousands of young people dancing in in
the middle of the night it was a peace
concert called the Nova concert and
these guys had the perfect St they found
all these young
kids and started shooting them just like
you know like H like Savages and and and
they killed hundreds so at the end of
the day at the end of the day ER we
didn't know exactly what was happening
but we already knew that probably we
lost some of our colleagues and uh and
that and that we didn't know really how
many we have lost and what was the
destiny because the batteries of their
telephones sometimes finished and then
they had connection and the Army was
also grabbling the the communications of
the terrorist couldn't communicate so
they lost communication and we were like
waiting to hear from them you know
what's going on so very very difficult
day I tell you I mean we go and sleep
for 48 hours
almost um and if you want to know what
is the outcome of
ubq er regretably out of the 13 people
that we have living in this communi is
two wor of
Deb and one is our uh our head
accountant who was working with the
other accountant who hband was she she
they they couldn't really stop them from
coming into the Refuge room they she and
her husband were shot and the two twins
10 months old
were left
alive the reason that they were left
alive is not that they didn't kill
babies because because they can't they
killed a lot of babies and even
decapitated them the reason these kids
were were kept alive is because their
CED would attract the soldiers to rescue
them and that way they could it was a
human trap to attract soldiers and shoot
them so h a horrible a horrible really
you know it's um it's macabus but that's
what happened but they is so
they had this leave and and and and then
the other one is a is our head engineer
who is second second plan manager
uo ER who was also shot dead luckily he
was defending his M family and he could
shoot so so the terrorist didn't want to
didn't wanted really to to deal with his
house because there was a a crazy guy
shooting from there they didn't know
they had already shot him dead so they
left them alone so he in a way saved her
her wife and three
daughters ER the other 11 were were were
lucky that they were alive because their
houses were burned but they didn't choke
and um but they of course lost family
and all the community and their most you
know close
friends um a true disaster a true
disaster
1,400 de
250 hostages 2,500 wound and uh and and
for me the most terrible thing is that
these communities that really you know
are the heart and soul of what you call
developing the land developing the
future creating communities you know
cooperating uh uh H in in Freedom to
make a life better and circular and
clean which is the motos of the this is
exactly the population that was shot
killed there and that is a that is a
true tragedy we need to put those
communities back immediately and we need
to come to live immediately to tell the
terror you will never win like that
that's not the way and we and we will
show you that there's no way we are
going to fall apart we will rebuild
these communities and uh and we will I
know we will we will
continue it's un it's unbelievable um so
along the same mindset of we will
continue and we will rebuild um you lost
employees you lost team members how did
the you how did you how did ubq continue
functioning over this let's say week
even how what what do you as a leader
how do you continue running this company
during this during this time we we look
we got we got we got very clear that the
first priority was to to be very very
close to our team members in Israel uh I
just want to make a prence we also have
a a very big team in the Netherlands we
have a plant a big plant in the
Netherlands and
yet all our attention was focused on the
welfare of our employees we really work
close to them we make sure that anything
that they needed in addition to whatever
the Goro and was able or not able to
give them we give them a they left those
those houses with with nothing I mean
they lost them so they needed food they
needed clothing they needed computers
they needed support and we were there
for them that was the first thing we did
in that week the second thing is that we
already spoke about if and when we will
be able to go back to the factory in
South H with a small team of people just
to take a material you know a part of
our stock material to to an outer space
so that we can ship it abroad and
continue supplying our customers from
the material we have in Israel so we
already organized an operation of
rescuing our our material from the
factory okay and on top of it we already
start working with with with our H team
leaders H Factory the sou on how to try
eventually and bring the factory back as
soon as possible because we knew that
was the only way to over overcome some
of the difficulties of these people
going back to work and trying to go back
to normality is the best remedy to
overcome that trauma which of course
will psychologically will be there but
but they needed that that uh that
ventilation to go back to work so we
prepared everything we're close to our
people uh we inform all our investors
all our employees around the world all
our suppliers we would send every 3 days
to everyone a different letter of course
because you address the letters
differently to each one of our
stakeholders informing them what we're
doing and that was extremely appreciated
by all our our you know ecosystem and
and and and and so they were part of of
of what we were going through and they
really were very supportive and that
helped us overcome these three difficult
first weeks were were were really need
to put our act together back again after
3 weeks we started organizing our teams
to go back we oriented places we
organized transportation and four weeks
later ubq was back in operations with
the with the with our team members and I
have to tell you that when I went went
the first day we were all very emotional
because we could see the rooms of our
colleagues empty and their photographs
and everything but we were so happy that
we could you know continue and that we
will show that the terror will never
stop us from doing the right thing and
and that spirit is is is is extremely
valuable and the resilience and
solidarity of these people is is beyond
anything I have ever seen and uh and I'm
so
proud our team members and in general of
the isra society has been very
supportive incredible thought and thank
you so much for sharing with me both
your your personal experience but your
leadership and and the what what sounds
to have been
a you know a tragedy for for for all of
us but but also for a company like qbq
but but what what a motive that
continuously came back at time over this
conversation is the imperativeness of
continuing rebuilding staying strong and
and the best remedy is to continue and
to continue and continue inspiring not
just locally but but internationally and
continue being a leader and uh and so I
can I can see how you you're living
through this this this pain but at the
same time you're you're leading through
it and and so as a a as an entrepreneur
I I thank you for that for that
leadership and for that inspiration so
so thank you very very much for for
everything and for this time here I'm
excited to share this with with every
body you know 51 days into the war it's
not enough to gain perspective
necessarily but already I feel like
there's there's a lot to be to be shared
here so thank you so much for everything
tto thank you Michael thank you I
appreciate
[Laughter]
it